if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumpsters
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
rushes
[Music]
big massive dumpsters
[Music]
all right welcome everybody there's just
too much and to too much news and too
many important things to talk about
to waste any more time on mimetic songs
so we're gonna get right away from that
i am sorry i'm late scheduled to start
about 20 minutes ago i had a massive
technical breakdown
where um let me just put it this way
if satan existed i imagine that
he they or she would wield their
power through windows updates that's
that's basically the way i would uh
characterize it
if i had to but yeah so we had we had
some technical issues to um
to deal with and i see people already
getting banned we have i haven't even
started people have already been banned
left and right
uh so what's going on listen i'm getting
increasingly concerned
that we are barreling towards trump
riots
the sequel um sometime in august
and the reason i say this is that
seemingly every day we realize
that although there probably is some
grift component to what is going on
right now
with donald trump um it appears that he
really thinks
he may be able to get back in power
in august and we learned today that it
is not just
trump who thinks he might be getting
quote reinstated by the way what does
that even mean we elect presidents and
then they're sworn in what does it even
mean to be reinstated it's ridiculous
you're no longer the president
uh two former republican senators
apparently believe the same thing this
appears to really be a real thing and
the scary part is not that it might
happen
the scary part is that when it doesn't
the q anon people
are going to go absolutely nuts and do
more violence once again so let me
kind of paint the picture for you
we first heard from the new york times
maggie haberman
that donald trump is privately telling
people
we got to watch what's going on with
these audits or
artists as some people say in arizona
and other places
and trump is starting to privately tell
people i think i might be back in office
in august why august we don't know it
was going to be march and then april and
then okay right so but
that's the original report it's denied
by people like lara trump
and others but then today we get this
tweet from maggie haberman this is an
article from the right wing national
review
which says maggie haberman is right
listen it's maggie haberman understated
the insanity of what's going on donald
trump
really does believe that he along with
two former republican senators will be
reinstated to office this summer
this is the right wing national review
okay whoa
i have an ad blocker on and i'm just
getting crushed guys what is happening
here
two days ago let's look at this two days
ago the new york times maggie haberman
reported that donald trump has been
telling a number of people he's in
contact with that he expects that he
will be reinstated by august
in response many figures on the right
reinserted
their fingers into their ears and
started screaming about fake news
instead they should have listened
because haberman's reporting was correct
i can attest this is charles cook
writing it
i can attest well where did it go from
speaking to an array of different
sources
that donald trump does indeed believe
genuinely
that he along with former senators david
perdue and martha mcsally
will be quote reinstated now the quotes
around reinstated must be used
because there is no such process in the
united states of america
understand reinstated your term is over
you didn't win that's it
after the office this summer after
audits of the 2020 election in arizona
georgia and a handful of other states
have been completed i can attest too
that trump is trying hard to recruit
journalists politicians
and other influential influential
figures to promulgate this belief
not as a fundraising tool or as an
infantile bit of trolling or a trial
balloon but as a fact
understand this for all this time we
were wondering
people would come to me and they would
say sir do you think
trump believes any of this stuff or do
you believe that it's just a grift to
raise money
and i would say i don't know it sort of
seems like a grift
maybe early trump thought maybe there
would be something here but i think it's
mostly a grip to raise money
um i was wrong and i am here right now
people to tell you i was wrong about two
things
and i'm coming to you to plead for
forgiveness number one
i thought it was mostly a grift and we
are even hearing from the right now
it's not a grift trump really thinks he
might
become president again sometime during
the next
period of time between now and january
of 2025.
i was wrong i thought it was really 99
of grift
number two i was wrong
that q anon would fade and never achieve
a significant following
i was wrong people i'm demanding
apologies on twitch i'm demanding
apologies on
on uh on youtube everywhere apologies
apologies okay
we ne so the the context here is
trump really thinks he might be
reinstated in august
uh apparently martha mcsally and david
perdue think they might be reinstated in
august
it's not just a grift and here's the key
20 of americans now believe at least one
q a non-conspiracy theory and in fact if
we're going to be thorough
and i kind of want to be thorough with
you guys today
let me actually find the article uh
wait a second where is it 20 of
americans here we go
look at this so this is about there's
enough people in the country that
believe this stuff
which is where the violence could come
from oh no now i have to allow ads can
you imagine
the ad blocker worked now i've got to
turn it off
okay check look at this look at how much
of a page there is
look at this little block of webpage oh
now i've got more these ads i mean it is
toxicity
toxicity by the way let me tell you
about blue chew
blue blocks as well as teddy stratford
shirts
sheath underwear these ads though are
insane okay
um 15 of americans agree with the q anon
statement that the u.s government media
and financial worlds are controlled by a
group of satan worshipping pedophiles
who run a global child sex trafficking
operation
20 percent of americans agree with the
statement there is a storm coming soon
that will sweep away the elites in power
and restore the rightful leaders
fifteen percent of americans agree that
because things have gotten so far off
track true american patriots may have to
resort to violence in order to save our
country
okay um one out of five people in this
country believes the q anon stuff
and simultaneously we are now learning
that donald trump
believes that he may be reinstated so
all of this
with trump's restarted rallies starting
within the next 10 to 14 days reportedly
i don't think it bodes particularly well
for the remainder of this year
um where do we even go from here
what let's read a little bit more of
this it will be this is a good
remember this is a right-wing article
this is from the national review
it will be tempting for weary
conservatives to dismiss this
information as old news
or as an irrelevance it will be tempting
too
to downplay the enormity of what is
being claimed or to change the subject
or to attack the messengers that they
must by implying they must hate trump
and his voters
but such temptations should be
assiduously avoided
we are not talking here about a fringe
figure within the republican tent
but about a man who hopes to make
support for his outlandish claims
a litmus test of sorts as he decides
whom to endorse for state and federal
contests in 22 and 24.
if you're wondering so now we're tying
it into the january
6th commission if you were wondering why
whatever number of republicans it was
voted against
the commission it's not just because the
commission
would incriminate them many of them have
guilty minds and and they should
a bunch of these republicans voted
against the commission
because they rightly have assessed
that donald trump is watching who is in
favor of the commission and who is
against it
and trump plans to have his naughty and
nice list his rhino
and real republican list going into 2022
and they don't want to be on trump's bad
side so
all of these stories that we've been
covering for the last several months the
audits
the delusions uh the restarting of the
rallies trump's desperation to reconnect
with his voters
continued belief from republicans not
only in queue and on conspiracies
but that donald trump is really the
president all
of this stuff together is now pointing
to an electorate
that we know they're willing to turn to
violence
because it happened on january 6th and
in sum total
uh this is all uh this is all
pretty wild people asking is there a
date for the for the august thing
i have no idea no there's no particular
date yet
um another article by the way this is an
important one also the washington post
a surreal submerged conspiratorial
trump-centered political universe still
thrives as if we didn't know this
this is by philip bump for more than
five years the rallies never stopped
it was a rally in phoenix in july 2015
that elevated trump's presidential
campaign into real contention
trump's rallies over the next 16 months
became cultural events
manifestations of the undercurrent of
support that ended up
tipping the scales that november even
after trump won the rallies continued
less than a month after the election was
called trump was back speaking
before adoring audiences this goes on to
say
um hold on let me see where did i want
to skip to
the rallies are loosely aimed at the
same oh this is now about the america
first rallies that are the gates green
rallies
the rallies are loosely aimed at the
same falsehood that trump has worked to
promote since his ouster
that he didn't lose last year at a large
retirement community in florida early
last month that's funny
gates and green encouraged the audience
to recognize trump as legitimate
president
which he isn't another stop on their
slap dash tour landed them in arizona
to promote the bizarre and tainted
election review effort being conducted
on behalf of some republicans in the
state
it's not just that they're leveraging
trump's style they're leveraging the new
energy of the trump movement
energy centered on wild and obviously
untrue claims
about the election this
is clearly coming and i am not here to
pretend to know
exactly what form it's going to take
because you know what
i i never thought q anon would get the
level of prominence that it got
and i thought the entire trump thing was
a grift at this point
it really seems that it's not merely a
grift
and that there is a large share remember
74 point something million people voted
for trump
you only need a few thousand of that 74
million
to go completely bonkers to
uh wreak absolute havoc on the united
states
so that's my concern i am not going to
underplay the risk now i hope that it
doesn't happen
but uh i underplayed the risk before
and that didn't work out so well all
right so that's the big picture of
what's going on
um oh man i've been ranting non-stop for
15 minutes
let me just thank a few people thank you
on twitch to troik's
benevolent goddess as well as real time
fan
life is good grab the twitch sub pizza
man drc number five
pink and blonde number six twenty month
subscribed pink and blonde
louis curtin number seven very much
appreciate that and yeah i'll open some
phone lines if we get to 100 today i
would love to do that
also from the standpoint of my website i
want to say thank you to sabrina white
who just signed up with the rapidly
expiring coupon code memorial21
and a big thank you as well to jonathan
balangan who just signed up on my
website as well
new members number eight and nine let me
get now before we get
i have so much other stuff to go over
with you guys you have no idea how much
we have to go over here
i do want to read some super chats death
row boat
says sir this is the super chat you will
be reading i did
von tucks says use linux ubuntu
with mate desktop or
kde are friendly to windows users
more control of the update schedule all
right
pair says maybe an nra sales pitch
compare the rebel politicians and weapon
makers
all right beautiful
andrew says the leftist punk rock band
rise against is releasing
releasing a new album tonight check out
the song the numbers tell me it's not
powerful
i will look at that greg says i forgive
you for being wrong david in times like
these it's hard to be certain about
anything
except for internet ads
there are people around me who believe q
anon i'm in europe i've heard that
there's even european q anon if you can
imagine anything more despicable
for your okra soup david says lily thank
you
sunil says david do you ever feel like
the average american doesn't take this
stuff as seriously as they should
absolutely absolutely
um i do want to say thank you to weather
boxer for gifting five subs as well as
astro lycos for the sub
napa skip dog has subscribed so has
margot cabot
and andre bavaria that's seven putting
us at 16.
drew says dream blunt rotation david
lynch david letterman david pakman
i think that's a compliment arresting
trump will help cut off q anon's fire
i don't see that happening we talk about
the elite of madness
the benefits of fear
dereten says as i leapt from my all-form
sofa
and spilled the mushroom coffee on my
teddy stratford shirt
i cannot help but feel this is trump
scaremongering for money
wow aggressive what do you think of alan
lichtman he's gotten every single
election year right
including 16 and 20. he says infighting
hurts the party in the white house dems
have it republicans don't
he's been on the show a couple of times
and i tend to value his analysis
i feel the arizona audit will lie and
say the
found they found fraud or create fraud
what do you think will happen if it
comes true no you know what i think will
happen
the arizona audit will find nothing and
then they'll say
that's evidence that they've covered up
the fraud really well
that's how conspiracy theorists work if
they find evidence they've found
evidence
if there's no evidence it's evidence
they covered up the evidence
this is how they work my friends um
okay and lastly thank you to andrew
gantz who has just signed up
at joinpackman.com let's get to a couple
of other things
oh okay hold on i have my agenda here um
how
is the new youtube channel doing it's
doing really well
we have dumped in 2340 subscribers
this is the channel on which clips from
this stream up here
as well as the garden tours and
everything
davidpakman.com pacman live this is the
new youtube channel
uh the be one of the first five thousand
it's a really special number if you're
one of the first five thousand
you're way ahead of everybody that comes
in after and you're basically holding
for the long term
so the new youtube channel doing really
really well
and it's only been up a few days and
it's all crazy what's going on there
okay number two a few people emailed me
about this
i didn't see it i didn't see it but i do
want to talk about it
uh people said david this is the short
the long and short of what the question
is
did you see levy rosman on his chest
stream
absolutely destroy the entire wealth
management and financial advising
industry i didn't see it i like levy i
i didn't see this um i'm going to give
my take on this and i think i know that
there are financial advisors and wealth
managers in
in the audience and this may alienate
some of them but i'm gonna say it anyway
okay
what are my credentials in this field i
have a master's
degree in business administration with a
focus on financial advising
um i interned at a wealth management
firm
and i have interviewed uh numerous
financial advisors for myself so that
that take it or leave it
okay i'm just giving you my credentials
be they pathetic or not or whatever okay
fine
i believe that um 99
of what financial advisors and wealth
managers
do for people you can learn
in a month okay and here's the thing
the world i have friends who are
financial advisors and wealth managers
okay guys the beautiful people there's
lots of industries that we don't really
need
i have lots of friends that are realtors
90
of what realtors do could be replaced by
uh just working with a lawyer a little
bit earlier and changing some systems
around but today's not about realtors
it's about financial advisors and wealth
managers
okay um in one here's the reality
financial advisors and wealth managers
make money
by convincing you that it's really
difficult to manage this stuff for
yourself
and oftentimes um
it's just not for people of average
intelligence
if you spend a month simply learning
about
basic tax strategy understanding what
types
of investments are tax advantaged the
difference between a roth i.r.a and
regular
all these different and then you simply
understand the way to win in the long
term
is not by picking individual stocks it's
not by picking individual stocks the way
you win in the long term
is you reduce you the costs of your
investment you can use
firms like betterment vanguard and
others where sometimes all you pay is
five measly basis points per year okay
you eliminate any emotionality
simply by coming up with an asset
allocation plan here's a really simple
one this is not advice but here's
something yeah people are saying you can
learn this in a week not a month
uh one way that people do it is you take
your age and you subtract it from 120
that's the percentage of your assets you
put in stocks
okay so if you're 35 120 minus 35
is 85. you put 85 percent in stocks you
put 15
in bonds lowest possible cost you say
well what stock fund
the widest possible total u.s
all right you want to get complicated
you take your stocks and you do 70
u.s 30 international then you do your
the rest in bonds okay
each year you drop the stocks by one
percent as you get a year older
and then you rebalance back to this
that's it guys that's it and
the way that financial advisors and
wealth management make money in part is
by convincing you
that you can do way better if you pay
them a one or two percent a year fee
that you need complicated instruments
now you want to pick some stocks
fine i've got six to eight percent in
individual stocks i've talked about what
that portfolio is consider it's
speculative
consider it speculative you want to
diversify into crypto
three to five percent in crypto great
okay
um i do think that jack bogle
and if you go beyond that even the
go to benjamin graham's writing from
1920
this stuff really is not as complicated
as the industry wants you to believe
now there are um
real questions that i think financial
advisors are valuable for
in my experience tax attorneys are
actually even more valuable so i've gone
to some of these folks and i go good
sirs i have five specific questions let
me pay you by the hour i just did this
last year
i had some specific questions about tax
implications
about some multi-state questions that i
had
about some of these different things and
i said what do you charge by the hour oh
we charge whatever it was right 250
bucks an hour
i want two hours of your time give me
answers to these questions
right i think that that can be very
valuable but with a lot of this other
stuff um
it's it's really an industry that
depends on people
not informing themselves are there some
cases where people's situations are
really complicated
sure yeah maybe i guess i guess sure
um but yeah i don't know exactly what
levy said but if levy's uh perspective
was similar
so here's like a question where let me
give you an example
for a lot of people here's like a
question where you would want a
financial advisor
i have a mortgage at 3.5 percent
the trump uh here's how much money is
left on the mortgage
the trump tax reform limited
the uh state and local tax deductions
which includes mortgage interest and
real estate taxes
here's how much cash i have in a bond
fund
is it worth it for me to pay off the
mortgage
that's a specific actionable question
for which a lot of people would be well
uh advised to hire someone to
evaluate that question okay
but for the most part really low cost
long term
passive investing come up with an asset
allocation do
you know the the bogglehead or bogle
head three
three fund portfolio etc very good none
of this is financial advice beautiful
let's move on
um let me say thank you to allies
as well as jay tandaway
ak cruiser and nolan for the twitch
subscriptions appreciate that guys that
puts us at 21.
and also big thank you to
renata azar for signing up on my website
with the coupon code
better21 remember that the code
memorial21 expires
uh tomorrow night all right i have one
unbanned request to which oh no i have
two
unbanned requests to adjudicate i don't
have my uh
gavel let's evaluate the first unban
request this is from a user
named vader's grandma they came in and
sent the following messages
looks like today f i i i i
yeah yeah igf
they were timed out and then they were
banned they then came in and said
sorry for the trolling i want to ask
your opinion on susan collins
that's a denial we're adults here that's
not how you get my attention we can't
encourage that kind of behavior
also another user named you dead showed
up
and said i never understand what biden
says it's unintelligible
um biden seems like a dementia patient
i'm here to laugh at the president who
wears diapers they were banned
they came back and said feel the burn
nah that's a perma-ban guys
that's a problem we just don't need that
crap so there is that
and we got that out of the way okay
let me go next to
[Music]
oh yeah this is a whole thing
um here's a question about the gnome
chomsky interview that came in via
voicemail let's listen to that
i did were you able to get noam chomsky
to purchase some sheath underpants
you know the topic of sheath underpants
didn't come up with noam chomsky i have
to admit
it didn't come up um
here's something about hunter biden that
came in
hey david it's eric from math again um i
got bad news for you the uh
hunter he's got bad news for me don't
worry about the emails you just gotta
worry about the images on there because
uh
i'm not gonna say but uh yeah
i've seen still images and it's
disgusting but
you'll cover that up and whatever
because i'm going to cover that up
because you know you are for these whack
jobs
and no matter what anyone what whack job
have i been for
ever does they're great and everyone
else is an
[ __ ] so just let you know
uh you're on the wrong side of this and
when it comes out i feel sorry for you
because you have no clue what's going on
and you think the thing with flynn is an
attempted coup
yeah no what does that mean that it's
going to be a real coup i don't even
understand that
and then here's something about
argentina let's see what this is
hey david if there is a war between
argentina and the united states
which side would you be on
[Laughter]
oh that is that is rich um you know
something makes me think it's not really
going to make a difference i think in
such a war the u.s would prevail
that's my instinct on that one i don't
think that that would be i don't think
that would be a close one
um and i would i would probably be
against the war
you know if there was a war between the
u.s and argentina i would probably be
against the war that's that's my
instinct on that one
okay um
let's go let's do a few more super chats
and then we're going to move on
svine sigurdsson from iceland says as an
outsider i was just wondering
if overall outrage focuses on a single
probable point
or just an attempt to influence
non-informed people
man i don't know what that question
means i'm sorry
yeah i don't know do you think there's a
chance active military or police would
join the potential coup
convinced trump is right anecdotally yes
i mean look at the january 6
riots the january 6 riots were filled
with off-duty police and
former or current members of the
military will the military support a
trump coup
no no it will not
and uh dalton haskin uh oh where did
that go
dalton haskins says david the blood
libel skeleton of q anon goes back a
thousand years
before unfortunately this iteration
won't go away so easily
david fan of the chat channel hope
you're doing well after all of the
anti-semitic incidents
thank you chris i appreciate that thank
you for continuing to provide great
content
okay let me just do a couple other
voicemails because i did have
speaking of um speaking of the
anti-semitism thing
i do have just a couple other voicemails
let me see if i can find them here
um
yeah so the the trans-obsessed woman now
seems to have shifted to being obsessed
with jews take a listen
i just found this uh other name for a
hebrew like a jewish person that i
thought
might cheer you up and um it's
pronounced goddess
anyways it means an african worker
oh my god so just a lot of fixation now
on judaism
uh here's another one i don't want to
say this to some anti-semitic because i
do
actually you know believe in a lot of
the regulations in the bible
i believe in spirituality like if i saw
somebody actually being jewish
if you saw someone being jewish that's
interesting
terminology that's could be could be
problematic terminology to be perfectly
frank
we think that was great but i haven't
ever seen that
no she's never seen anyone being jewish
i mean
sometimes i feel like people are mixing
with certain genetics
to uh oh we're starting to get almost
into like uh
phrenology here let's keep going um
i think that there was like one more
from this
gentle lady here it is
[Music]
oh and um one more thing is this time
calling on speaker
a school that i went to in vermont it
was like for
jewish people or something she went to a
school hold on a second
she went to a school in vermont that was
for jewish people or something but she
said in the
other voicemail she's never seen someone
being jewish that's not making a lot of
sense to me
and i'm not jewish and they didn't i i
died i guess yeah
did you say anything about judaism
i learned like a little bit about
science and stuff but it was mainly
about poetry and stuff like that
wow jewish school taught mostly poetry
that's interesting
get off my stream all right
that's enough let's uh
let's let's move on here thank you to
chantilly as well as david chadman now
subscribe
20 months thanks to beta star as well
putting us at 25 and just a reminder
guys the number one way that i've read
about in medical journals to support
this show
is to get a membership at
joinedpakman.com the memorial day coupon
code
expires tomorrow night that code is
memorial 21
it gives you a year membership for 19
bucks
it gives you a monthly membership for a
dollar ninety a month
our attorney accountant
and our entire staff was beating down
the door
when i was setting up this coupon code
saying do not do this
do not do this and i double locked it
there's a reason i put a deadbolt on the
studio door
and i did it okay don't make me regret
that
don't make me regret that because that's
a really really big thing
okay quick fruit update for those of you
who follow me on
instagram um i ate this is a really
interesting kind of uh strawberry i ate
one of these today
really really good i have to tell you i
would eat one of these again
um no this is a it's a dragon fruit i
really recommend this fruit
guys this is a really really strong
recommendation from me
it is delicious it is delicious and this
yellow one is sweeter
than the one that's red on the outside
and
um it's almost like it's almost like a
kiwi
consistency with bigger seeds it's one
of my favorite new fruits
i just learned about it all right
so i have not had the dragon fruit
that's purple on the inside i want to
find that
i have not been able to find it anywhere
in the northeast i've been scouring all
over the place for it
but and these are not these are like
kiwi seeds they're not like poppy seeds
these are like kiwi seeds
delicious really really great so anyway
if you're into fruit and fruit related
posts you can follow me on instagram
um we did this already we did this i'm
just clearing things out of here
um okay
oh and people saying check pacman live
let's see
wow look at that strong growth on pacman
live this is the second youtube channel
and we've got some some cool stuff
happening over there totally new channel
and uh davidpakman.com pacman live yeah
really really great stuff we just
launched this
we just launched this okay let's get
into
the rudy giuliani uh podcast a bunch of
people wrote to me and said david
rudy interviewed someone who roomed
with a communist it's not even an
interview with a communist it was just
somebody whose roommate was a communist
and you really got to see it
let's check it out i haven't
pre-screened this so let's uh let's just
start let's dive in
giuliani and i'm back with another
edition of rudy's common sense
so today we have with us a very
interesting guest
who i think can open up our eyes to many
things that are going on
in this country maybe give us a little
more of a sense of where it's all coming
from
to be perfectly frank i'd be more
interested in an interview with someone
whose roommate had 10 cats
than with someone whose roommate was a
communist like living with the
communists seems easier than living with
the person with the 10 cats that's just
me but i don't know if that's as
interesting to rudy morgenstager's
morgan is the founder and the creator of
an organization that has a name that i
just love
yeah young americans against socialism
[Music]
i have to believe her her decision to to
do this was prophetic
yeah this is exactly what if we didn't
have it we'd have to create right now
and morgan is a young woman but a very
very accomplished young woman she's
already run a
very credible race for public office in
a
democratic district against a democratic
uh
opponent in a in a democratic year
which all counts you know that this only
got 23 000 views somehow
she got 44 of the vote that means um
that was once described to me by a great
american senator whereas when you run a
good race and you just lose
you have money in the bank so i don't
know how much money
that i don't know how much money morgan
has in the bank but she's got a lot of
political money in the bank
and she is darn darn good here we go how
did it get started
well again thank you for the opportunity
to come and speak with you oh my
pleasure
i i i can't thank you enough this almost
seems like it didn't happen live did you
is something weird about these cuts
where it seems almost like
the these people's parts were recorded
separately it's really weird the way
it's cut
to understand why i would start an
organization with this name and this
mission really requires a little back
story
i'm from upstate new york i actually
just moved to texas though
so um yesterday moved into my house and
it's just been a whirlwind of a weekend
but unlike many of the people who have
led a blue state and have now arrived in
texas or florida or nashville
i think this is the actress who played
borat's daughter yeah yeah
but when i was in upstate new york i
grew up under the cuomo administration
and my dad was a colonel in the military
now call it the cuomo regime you might
as well right
he's in the army reserves as a colonel
still and my family didn't raise me to
be political but they at least raised me
to have a very great respect for
american values
america's history our founding and of
course just history in general learning
from history in order to not repeat it
and you know that lesson comes up so
many times these days as my generation
fails to understand what we are really
going through as a country
uh but i was from upstate new york what
was the question
why did you start this group i'm gonna
skip ah
i can't do the preamble let's go to
rudy's next question
promises from a communist and i realized
that so many young americans like me
maybe we think that we know what we
would say if we're put in this situation
maybe we feel like we understand
american values american history
world history politics economics all of
that stuff
but then right there in that moment even
i didn't know what to say and so i
started young americans against
socialism
to make educational videos and content
that we're we're five minutes in
remember the question was why did you
start this
she's been speaking for four minutes and
the answer could have just been this i
started to make educational videos and
content
we'll equip young americans with the
basic information that they need so that
when they enter these conversations with
leftists because we know that it's going
to keep happening more and more
they have the intellectual ammunition to
really fight back and win that
conversation
so in essence you educated yourself so
you can educate others
and if you if you could acquire the
knowledge for yourself which you did you
then
you you then want to pass it on to
others absolutely who would find this
interesting guys seriously who on earth
would find this even remotely
interesting
the numbers are a little crazy and i'm
actually quite optimistic about it i
don't know if you've seen them but
in 2019 gallup said that 58
of young americans would choose
socialism over capitalism
and a victims of communism poll that
they did with yougov showed that 70
of young americans would vote for a
socialist when you could you tell us
young what
uh 25 younger 30
younger uh millennials and gen z so it
was the two
young generations uh up until about 35
years old
okay that's a big that's a big group
definitely and what's interesting too
is they aren't the largest voting blocks
it's weird that the room tone from her
audio cuts abruptly every time they cut
to rudy it's just
something technically is happening here
that's weird yet but they will be by
about
2028 gen z and millennials now
what was interesting about these numbers
is you have 70 of young americans saying
they want to seize the means of
production right
i highly doubt they've ever heard that
term before they cannot tell you what
that means and in reality socialism is
that economic step
for communism because it's the
government apparently this entire
interview was almost knocked offline by
a win but
by an errant windows update i read that
taking over
the means of production seizing the
means of uh production of private
business and private industry
so when i see these numbers i think my
generation
cannot possibly want that if they fully
understood they wouldn't want it
and what man what what a just pointless
interview
let's see where rudy sells something
let's see young americans can make that
connection
and we are suffering right now because a
communist regime lied and suppressed the
truth
from the world this would be a good time
to take a short break
i accomplished a lot in 2020 exposing
the truth
establishing the relationship with you
working tirelessly
is he selling coins now for america and
i came to know the work
and value of the people at american
hartford gold oh my god
you see you buy gold not only for what
you know
but you buy gold for what you don't know
right
american hartford gold is the company
you can trust
when it comes to buying gold they sell
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door
or inside of your ira they'll deliver
they'll insert the coins right into your
ira
all right so there's that let's see if
there's any other ads here i mean quite
frankly
oh look here's one i think something oh
rudy's uh
like some kind of computer thing let's
see by a bad man but not a madman
this would be a good time to take a
short break your credit card company
found
suspicious charges on your card that
simple identity theft
it's annoying but they cover it so this
is comedy gold yeah
type of fraud you really need to worry
about home
title theft a devastating crime home
title theft
what anybody who owns a home has title
insurance right
how how is this even a product anyone
could need
it takes you off your home's title and
you're not covered
by insurance or most identity theft
programs
i don't even understand the crime so you
have title insurance
but there's someone steals the title
and it's not covered that's why you need
home
title mock here's how easy it is for
cyber criminals uh-oh whoa
this guy's wearing a hoodie to get you
the title documents to our homes are
kept online
the thief forges your signature on a
quick claim deed
stating you just sold your home and he's
the new
owner then he borrows money using your
home's equity
man that's a freaking big scam how i
don't even know
i mean that that seems like a difficult
scam to pull off
i i know a little bit about this i've
been involved in a lot of real estate
transactions
it seems there are far easier ways to
scam people
uh does anybody know like is it could
this
really happen as easily as he's pointing
it out like the amount of paperwork to
forge a quick claim deed don't you then
have to file it
with with the this the hall of records
and then go i this this seems like an
incredibly unlikely scam
leaves you in debt you won't know until
late payment or eviction notices arrive
the instant home title lock detects
someone tampering with your home's title
they help shut it down let's get you
protected
go to home title oh my god gingrich is
on the website dot com and register your
address
to see if you're already right doesn't
it have to be it has to be notarized by
an attorney
and then filed with the city what a
weird scam
what a weird weird scam all right let's
do what just one more ad
because the um the actual interview is
is
you know just go in the toilet flushed
10 or 15 times let's see if there's any
other ads that rudy does here
the interview continues when would be
another time to take a short break
oh here we go hold on here's another one
of a wide assortment of other incredible
products
okay presented without comment presented
without comment it's like a mattress
topper sheets
towels and slippers and more
listeners have helped build my pillow
into the incredible company it is today
and mike lindell wants to he seems
genuinely angry that there are ads
give back to all of you pick some
pillows or pick several of the other
great products
and you can get super discounts on my
pillow
products by going to mypillow.com
promo code rudy right call
1-800-725-7759
promo code rudy right now should i call
that number should we call uh
should we call my pillow that's that
could be an interesting thing to do
we could speak to someone all right i
think we're done with this
i think we're done with this guys um
okay so that's that uh let me just make
sure i get everybody thanked here i oh
wow
huge dumps of memberships on the website
carrie mcelray
just signed up with the code memorial21
nathan landick just signed up on my
website
pair tieren has signed up on the website
rick edmondson has just signed up
jonathan zablin as well as diego
alessandro
are new members hayley brady
and deborah smith have just signed up
summer vance as well as austin swann
are new members this is nuts zach rogers
and annette spalding that's 12.
jason iverson and ben schneer have
signed up that's 14
wow putting us at 39
also thanks over on twitch to christina
as well as
warwick for the
subscriptions putting us at 41.
appreciate that guys oh and sorry
uh terry zablin didn't i mention terry
zablin already in any case another
membership from terry zablin
number 42. so people want me to call my
pillow
what would i even say and you know what
i don't know
like there could be some legal issues
with that
one-party two-party consent let me not
do that right now that could that could
actually i don't want to get into any
legal problems
that's not so good let me look at a
couple of other super chats here
these trump events are going to cause
mass covet outbreaks doesn't seem to be
talked about
i don't really think they will i think
that you know these events are outside
and even with just like 30 percent of
people vaccinated
um i i think they probably won't
david i got married in december and
bought a ts shirt for the occasion
what's ts i don't wear it much oh teddy
stratford
i don't wear it much but it was great
for the wedding thanks beautiful
beautiful chakaseki says were any plant
fibers found on the arizona ballots
yeah supposedly they found plant fibers
on the arizona ballots from a very rare
type of dragon fruit
and uh caused a lot of problems for
people
any advice on research tips and methods
on identifying and filtering
disinformation yes
uh you've got to be dealing with primary
sources when you see an article on
facebook and it's one of those websites
that's summarizing an article you've got
to go to the original source
start with the original source that's my
recommendation
john says i hate to be the bearer of bad
news
fouchy's emails could help the gop
in 22 if republicans will win in 22
they might actually impeach fauci
what keep in mind this is the current
gop we're talking about
i think dr fouch is going to be retired
very soon he's almost 81.
um i think i think dr fauci is is going
to be fine
okay all right let's continue um
oh okay here's the next thing i wanted
to look at apparently
jessie lee peterson was interviewed on
oan
about white pride or something this is
this is bizarre
um i've not pre-screened this but let's
take a look at it together
we should have never fallen for this
idea that oh we just want to come out of
the closet
just let us out of the closet and then
they said oh we want to go to
church but we don't want to be talked
about at church
so a lot of preachers stop mentioning
that homosexuality is wrong
that something has gone wrong and they
must repent
and return together do you say that
sub-sahara is wrong what was that word
he said
sub-sahara why that's weird what's wrong
with sub-sahara
now they have taken over the churches
there are a lot of preachers who are
afraid to speak out against
so-called pride month you know i started
the uh white history month in july why
this is our fourth year coming up when
we are celebrating
even oan must think this is crazy right
white history
and what i've noticed that in america a
country that was
founded by white people and created by
white people one of the greatest country
on this side of heaven
one of them and so white people invited
all these other
allow this all this other stuff to
happen but you could celebrate
everything but white history we must
remember why
you can't celebrate juan history
because it wasn't for that there would
be no america and so they got
black history women history mexican
history
so-called gay pride what's what's
happening about being perverted there's
nothing good about that
living in sin right and but we celebrate
i don't but they celebrate that
but when it comes to white history
they're afraid to even mention
white history but we got to bring that
back because that's what made america
great
we got to show our appreciation and not
one christian
should be selling what is he talking
about celebrating gay pride they should
be praying that these people
repent and overcome the fallen state
return to the father
god is not pleased and allowed that his
children are allowing this to happen
in a christian country it's not a
secular country
it's a christian country so we got to
bring back christianity and love
you're exactly right because all of us
are fallen in sin we all have our sins
and our flaws and our vices but we don't
make that the center of our personality
we don't identify it
wow it's not too crazy for oan she likes
it
that's nuts i thought this would even be
too much for them
if someone's a liar they shouldn't go
around and say have a lying flag
and you know say i you know i'm a liar
and that's who i am and that's
everything that you need to know about
me
no because as christians and in
christian nation we find our identity
our our identity in jesus christ
oh my god that is something else huh
that is really something else jesse
refuses to even use the coupon code on
my website because he thinks it's too
self-righteous
um man that is that is wild that is wild
uh big thank you to kate michelle for
the website membership i appreciate that
kate jordan dean just signed up using
the code memorial21
charles white just signed up on my
website also thanks to michael maciera
who just grabbed a membership of putting
us at 46.
also a big thank you on twitch to
mandermeyer suwanu
and puffin time putting us at 49.
really crazy stuff okay all right let's
go now to a review
of one of my old wacky interviews people
have been absolutely loving this this is
one that is not
very well known this is an anti-gay
pastor
explaining to me how his wife
stretched him okay bizarre interview
let's dig right in classic interview
we're going back to uh
sister christ it is a combination of the
merger took place in the early 60s
between the evangelical and reformed
church
congregational church uh they're very
liberal
and um our partners
uh so to speak with the disciples of
christ
uh if you're ordained to want to be a
minister in the other
and and vice versa um it seems here
lately a lot of the church growth has
come because of
uh uh mcc churches that left the
metropolitan community church and joined
the ucc
i don't even i think that the premise
was that this guy left his own church
because the church wasn't anti-gay
enough uh but
okay so what let's let's that give tells
us what it is but
i don't i want to get right into kind of
your situation so
you're going to be stepping down as
pastor of the goltry oklahoma ucc church
and the issue you have a problem with is
same-sex marriage so
outline what is the church's position
and what is your position that is so
different that it's causing you to
resign
well actually the local level they agree
with me
um but uh the problem is that they don't
want to leave the denomination
they're great people but so i think so
let me reframe it because i want to
walk people through it uh churches in
the ucc
recognize and can solemnize same-sex
marriage and that's what you disagree
with right i just want to be totally
explicit so our audience
knows what we're talking about
absolutely i i first
became a part of the ucc back in 2008
and was driving down to oklahoma city i
was actually a part of a church that's
mostly gay and lesbian
for a while and then once i graduated
seminary
um i had to find a preaching position
uh but the more i
the more i personal study i did on my
own
uh the more i realized that what i was
what i had been taught
uh in seminary and what i learned
through the denomination
wasn't accurate so explain that so
i remember that i was really confused
about this interview where i think i was
wondering why i was even doing it
your view of same-sex marriage
i um i define marriages between a man
and a woman
that comes from the bible what i've
discovered over
dealing with people through in the
denomination is that
the more that they value experience over
scripture the more liberal they are
and the more that they value the bible
over experience
then the more conservative they tend to
be now as someone who has studied this
and is
is a a student of of knowledge so to
speak
uh wouldn't it tell you that if people
base
their lives and their points of views
more
on their experience and their thinking
than on what a book
purportedly written by god tells them
maybe
that's more what we should be listening
to maybe experience and logic
tell us more about how we should treat
gay and lesbian couples
than a book clearly written by humans
but supposedly written by god tells us
maybe
maybe we could learn from that well
let me make one thing clear and this is
probably where some conservatives would
disagree with me on is that i don't
think of this as being
in salvation i think there are people
who are
uh gay and lesbian who are genuinely
saved that's nice
on who i will see on the other side okay
and
he's expecting like my experience with
cathedral of hope
he's expecting to see some gays and
lesbians in heaven is what he's telling
us
is that these people are genuinely
wanting to do
the right thing uh they do reach out to
people at the
gay pride event and there are thousands
of people there
and it was really disheartening you know
it's like the sunday night service after
that weekend would take place
and you might have three or four new
people show up when you
literally handed out thousands of flyers
and buttons and
you had people participate in this
parade either on friday or saturday
oh man and then very few people showed
up so
yeah that could be tough but the
salvation of the people
of cathedral of hope at all yeah and i'm
not either but but salvation aside just
for a second
it sounds like your opposition to gay
marriage lesbian marriage is primarily
bible-based in other words you didn't
mention one anti-gay argument which is
it's not
natural you didn't mention the it
doesn't lead to reproduction you didn't
mention well it's a legal redefinition
and i don't like that
correct me if i'm wrong but your
opposition is mostly bible-based is that
right
well i would say that and here's the
thing that really kind of threw a red
flag up for me
is that a lot of the people i spoke with
uh that are gay and lesbian
um whenever i would mention things like
uh bigamy polygamy and other things
they never really wanted to draw the
line there they never really wanted to
say well that stuff is bad
um what i'm hearing now uh
is the idea of marriage equality for
everybody
we'll have to have some kind of limits
because if you don't
then then then what are you defining
marriage as well that's interesting
because and again you and i are talking
we're not having a legal discussion
obviously
religious texts have no bearing at all
on
on legal structure in this country
whether you agree with that or not with
me
we're leaving that out for this
conversation but let's address it from
the point of view of the bible
the bible talks about men with multiple
wives men with multiple wives and
concubines
etc etc so is it not arbitrary to say
that because of the bible
you are against gay marriage for example
although the bible talks about multiple
wives concubines etcetera it talks about
stoning your
the the your wife if she's not a virgin
on the wedding day etc
isn't it all just kind of cherry picking
well the thing about that is i'm glad
you brought it up is that you he seems
thrilled i brought it up really can't
find one example of a
healthy relationship where where
somebody did have multiple wives i think
uh the bible mentions in first
corinthians that
we have the old testament as an example
for us
and really if you think about it could
you really have
two three four wives and love each one
of them equally and the same and i don't
think you can so let's use that
i like that i like that you're applying
that question which is let's just think
about this logically and say
can you really be married to four people
and love them equally and have that type
of relationship and you're thinking the
answer is no
what is it about a relationship between
one man and one woman
uh i'm sorry between two men or between
two women
where you couldn't have the same type of
love that you have in a
male-female relationship applying just
the kind of casual uh
logic test that you applied just a
second ago well
to add something further to the design
of marriage i think the thing that makes
sense this guy will not answer any
questions really
so great is that you're you're married
to somebody who thinks differently
you do buy it during the last 13 plus
years
my wife has challenged me stretched me
[Laughter]
oh man uh really your wife is
stretched to you i would say well just
when i was when i first got married i
was very selfish
and very self-centered and i did not
even realize how
much so during the time we've been
married i've learned how to
care for others in a way that you know
but james what you're dealing with what
you're saying james if i may
you're going down an incredibly
misogynistic path which is suggesting
that only women can teach men how to
care for others
you're also using very anecdotal
evidence which as
as a student who as someone who who is
an educated person
right i'm sure you know that anecdotal
evidence is not really what we should
talk about to discuss broad policy or
ideas
it seems incredibly offensive to so many
men to say that women are what is needed
to learn to care about others well i
think it goes two ways i think there are
things that
she's learned about life for me as well
the the
i'm contrasting that to two men or two
women because
in least in my opinion it's a
mirror image you're you're with somebody
who
does think that's a pretty funny so new
grongler
said i want to see young david debate
current david
a project that could be an historic
event in david pakman show history would
be if someone can do
me interviewing myself and like arguing
with me from two different
interviews or even from a couple of
different interviews put together
that that could be done really really
well
i'm gonna put that challenge out there
if people want to put something like
that together
that would likely that could be giga
viral
like you do and isn't really going to
challenge you
on certain things i just think that this
is a very silly argument though james
because the
conversation is silly you think the same
as anyone else who is the same
gender as you and therefore you wouldn't
learn from
from marriage i i've i've honestly it's
an interest
i'm interested in this idea because i've
never heard it before but
it's not a very strong argument is it no
uh well we'll have to agree to disagree
on that one uh i
i know me personally my life is very
fulfilling
uh and now if you were attracted to men
if you were born just being attracted to
men
would you not be fulfilled if you were
able to marry the man that you loved
hypothetically right would you would you
not find fulfillment in that
hmm that's an interesting question i
probably
it's almost like he'd never considered
it before
if i were gay would i find it fulfilling
to be with a man
[Music]
honestly i don't know i i i'm too i'm
too
it's so hard for you to imagine not
being straight because
you were born straight correct
um yeah i i'm not going to completely
dismiss the science that
i think you're referring to but i think
there needs to be more done
as far as whether or not you can be born
gay i think there needs to be more
scientific research
but so mike my question to you is to say
did you ever decide
james you when you were i don't know
seven to say okay well right now i'm
completely neutral between being
attracted to men or women
i think i'm going to choose to be
attracted to women you never had that
revelation did you
uh well most
oh my god i forgot about this part of
the interview
so my time up until the age of 10 i was
either playing basketball football or
kickball so
that's fair perfectly fair so at 10 is
when is that when you made the decision
you could have gone either way you could
have been into guys you could have been
into girls
and you said well i'm ten i've played
enough kickball now i'm going to choose
to be into women is that how it went for
you
or did you at some point just realize
you're attracted to women
that's an interesting question who's the
actual first girl i was
attracted to and it's like the question
isn't who was the first girl
man this it really seems like he's not
considered this stuff
or he's uncomfortable with the line of
questioning is another possibility
that's another possibility that that
would be sad if that's the case
but oh i don't know it's
it's kind of strange probably sixth
grade i knew a girl named shannon who
had
uh failed the grade and so she was a
little bit more um
physically mature than some of the roles
and
uh so you were attracted you were
attracted to your classmates breasts and
that was
a that was a physical reaction you had
you never said
i'm going to decide today to like my
classmates breasts that just happened
okay i think i i see that you're kind of
putting up some obstacles but i think
the audience kind of gets where i'm
going with this
we are out of time james i wish you the
best of luck i'm sorry
that your opposition to marriage
equality is leaving you to leave your
position
i hope you find a new position and i do
thank you for joining us
thank you so much have a great day yeah
we had to wrap up pretty quick there
man that i forgot about some of that
stuff that's pretty interesting i'm not
gonna lie
some of that i find actually pretty
pretty interesting uh okay
let me get to a few of these other super
chats and then i want to check in about
what's happening on newsmax i do want to
say thank you to cher williams who just
signed up on my website as well as
brandon corwin
thank you to walter mckennath
as well as matthew esworthy all four
folks
great people signing up on my website
thanks also
to um oh i guess that's it on twitch
maybe kathy bates i'm not sure
but did i mention kathy bates let's just
do it number 54.
okay other super chats coming in
um dp sir don't you think q and on
cuckoos
will fade away with america opening back
up post vaccine i fear that they will
not
oh my god it's sean spicer look at this
talked about in past shows
if why is the audio terrible keep adding
these layers on and fact checking
um you've got to wonder whether or not
we're just going down a a road where
more of the right continues to get
censored
yeah absolutely and if if you don't have
one part of the party who's willing to
hold them accountable it's an issue you
know you brought up europe
i actually think they've done a really
good job of holding tech accountable
they've been on many cases year after
year and they have hounded them and they
have charged them
large amounts they're still in um
okay all right let's see what else is on
people's minds via super chat here
you think trump maybe just has syphilis
i don't know
i'm not in a position to make that call
whoa hold on i just lost a whole bunch
of these
shane says hey david what do you think
of chris hedges view that the american
empire will decline over the next two
decades
i i think it's possible i think any of
those predictions
are you can always find somebody who
makes a prediction and it's right
um i i think it's very hard to really
predict
trump supporters are fueled by blatant
ignorance
okay this is a spanish one hola por
arizona okay congratulations to the
mexican soccer team
chris asul or blue cross for their ninth
championship very exciting huge
congratulations
hey dave got that magic spoon cereal
great with
almond milk good call great to hear it
tim says david icke a conspiracy
propagator
just released a motivational
motivational video it's a call to
rise up and fight evil the timing is
unsettling another piece of ammo for a
potential coup
i'm not even gonna play it not even
gonna play it
oh my god look at this advertisement on
newsmax look at this
popular semi-automatic modern rifles
handguns and shotguns
any magazine with a capacity over 10
rounds special license requirement to
keep your currently owned
semi-automatic guns gun confiscation
through a so-called government buyback
we must stand up against schumer and
feinstein's attempt to take away your
second amendment rights
please take action now by going to save
to a
dot us really low budget really really
low budget
edward says watch out for those golden
dragon fruits eat too many
you'll be in the bathroom longer than
you want oh my god
um i mean you know i'm not having a
dozen of these things
guys please give me the link to your new
channel can't find the page
it is davidpakman.com
slash pacman live it's right here
davidpakman.com pacmanlive
and it is a stunning
stunning new channel that we are
building up
um yeah that's the link
davidpakman.compacmanlife
boom look at that little drop in of 10
new subs there
uh yeah it's happening and we'll check
back in on it everybody
don't don't worry other super chats
there is no demonstrable credible
evidence showing that trans people have
unfair advantage in sport if you refuse
to research and educate yourself on the
subject please refrain from discussing i
don't know if the message is to me
i have researched it i found that in
some cases and in some sports that is
true
and in other case cases it is not when's
the hot tub stream david i don't have a
hot tub
honest question how can we conclude the
drop in covered cases
due to vaccines and not seasonal trends
since we were at levels
similar to last summer the deaths last
summer were significantly higher
the trajectory is different and very
soon we will be far far lower just give
it another three weeks
and you will see that it is very much
not the case
i went to a small liberal arts college
half of my friends roomed with
communists
okay rudy's super fraud detection voting
machine stop the fraud you really got to
worry about
yes why is the outlook on house 2022 so
bad for democrats
it tends to be bad for the party that
wins the white house
in the first midterm that's just a
historical it's an historical reality
frankie says should have dr umar on one
day would bring double a views good
vibes don't know who that is okay i'd
have to research that i don't know who
that is
need gardening tips ever grown
strawberries yes i have a
second year strawberry plant right now
and it's going
really really well really well
i love the david pakman show forgot the
coupon code again
david parkman doesn't even burn i'm more
concerned about the state of the country
than i was when big orange head was in
the oval office there's some scary stuff
going on
i mean look at these ads on newsmax
right this should scare all of us
protect our freedom
[Music]
our constitution and our way of life
is this child abuse right here we will
always salute you
this is wild tonight we are a country
awakened to danger
and called to defend very special
special on 9 11.
um john says the scam is that you will
buy insurance for something that never
happens the company never has to pay out
uh who ended up getting the new producer
job we've we've hired i mean it's no one
you know
we've made we've hired someone we got
350 applications we narrowed it down
and we are fully staffed right now
fully staffed excellent observation from
the pastor people who don't think are
naturally conservative
he was selfish but now he gives his
whole
existence to her yeah i've been sending
in
fbi tips on cue crazies saying there
will be a bloodbath on july 4.
now trump is saying he will be back in
power by august
dominic says one to cause suffering
unnecessarily is immoral
two to get meat you must cause suffering
three eating meat isn't necessary for
getting meat is immoral all right
this message brought to you by a vegan
edward whoa hold on edward says so he's
saying he grew up around a lot of balls
come on guys come on
this show is so one-sided propaganda
i hope that was worth two bucks
australian can't get on
can't get on what
why can cyber criminals not afford to
heat their homes and always have to wear
hoodies
i don't know mike says david how long
until masks go away completely i don't
know
i don't know but i'm seeing fewer and
fewer of them everywhere already
dr umar is a black supremacist okay yeah
i don't we don't really do black
supremacy stuff on this show
but i can investigate it thanks to big
ryan live
as well as photo fitter for the twitch
prime subs numbers 55 and
56. uh also want to say thank you to
lawrence rubin
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code memorial21
um so they're are they just running
old interviews on newsmax well that's
the fashionable word these days i guess
liber
a conservative is no longer just that
he's a libertarian
there always has been because how do we
call a liberal
you know someone very profoundly once
said many years ago that if fascism ever
comes to america it'll come in the name
of
liberalism and what is fascism oh that
certainly was proven wrong the last four
years hasn't it
that uh that seems very very much very
much
inaccurate that's for sure uh all right
thanks everybody we got through
all of my material we spent an hour and
a half together
thank you for joining me that does it
for today
i will be back with you it's gonna be so
soon it'll feel like a continuous stream